hey everyone welcome to guessingtv where
you can find weekly videos on minimalism
and healthy living to help you live a
simpler happier life
today i'm going to share with you seven
books that completely changed my life
for the better now in all fairness to
the books i'm going to share them in the
order in which i read them instead of
which is better which is worst
because i genuinely believe that each
one of them played a role in shaping my
life in some sort of way
book number one dave ramsey's the total
money makeover
i unfortunately don't have this as a
hardcover to show you
because it's a traveling book it's one
that was gifted to me
i gifted to someone else in the hopes
that the cycle will continue
because it just really did turn my life
around
dave ramsey my life would be different
without you
when my husband and i got married we had
debt but i didn't see what the big deal
was
every day that i was off work i'd go
shopping i'd buy some five shirts two
dresses
and another two candle holders for my 20
candles that were already stashed in a
closet somewhere
but when i came across dave ramsey i
realized that i was trying to live a
life as though i had everything
but when you looked at my bank account i
truly had nothing
i love this book because it's very well
structured first of all it motivates you
to be debt free it kind of shows you
what your life could be if you were
financially independent then it actually
gives you clear steps to follow
to get there and for a very analytical
person like me
this was awesome because i could
actually visualize
step one step two step three and i could
see the progress that we were making
which motivated us even more this book
changed my life in three main ways
number one it unintentionally led me to
minimalism
because through our debt-free journey we
ended up selling a lot of our junk
we ended up getting rid of our tv the
video games the boredom shopping
and we embraced a more abundant life
with less clutter
and less chaos and number two i love
that he comes from a faith-based
perspective
because i've been judged and criticized
for members of my own church community
specifically
because many view the desire of wealth
as a sin
and they'll often quote money is the
root of all evil
no the love of money is this book helped
me to see
that it's okay to desire a life of
financial abundance
if my motivations come from a greater
good and number three it helps me to see
that i can
live a life of financial abundance this
was huge for me because i grew up poor
and i had this victim mentality
where i saw the riches being up here me
being down here and i never clicked in
my brain that
i could be financially independent and
they weren't up here i wasn't down there
we were actually equal and i can get
there
they have the same value and worth as i
do as a human being
but they learned how to manage money
better so if i wanted to get there
i better learn their tricks book number
two is
acres of diamonds from russell conwell i
actually have this one in spanish so the
cover i believe is a bit different
than it's normally designed in the
english version but i've actually been
able to
access the abridged version on audiobook
on the hoopla app which is totally free
you just use your library card i love
this book because it kind of tells you a
story so it makes you
think about your life and where you are
and where you want to go
the topic is on success and
self-development but it has a main focus
on
wealth and the pursuit of money this
book helped me to view money differently
it helped me by showing me two main
lessons number one that it was okay and
it was good
to pursue wealth if i did good things
with it and number two that i have to
come from a place of service in a place
of love because
if i seek well for my own desires for my
own ego
then i might just get there to realize
that i missed out on what truly mattered
to me
in the process so if you're into books
that have stories and kind of make you
reflect on your life then this might be
a good option for you
book number three hands down life
changer for sure
crucial conversations tools for talking
when the stakes are high i read this
book about a year and a half ago because
i was trying to improve my leadership
skills and my communication skills
and if you want to be a better leader
communication has got to be a skill that
you have
and this book helped me tremendously
both in my career and my personal life
because
i had zero communication skills my tools
or my skills were usually to use the
fight-or-flight method
i didn't know how to stay calm and
collected during an intense argument
this book gives you examples of
effective versus ineffective
communication skills
and then it actually breaks them down
for you to give you steps and tools
to better your communication i love the
way that this book is laid out because
it's very organized and structured and
it's very easy to read and
understand and i can definitely attest
to the fact that this book
changed heated conversations for me i
had other examples but one clear example
that i remember is when i had a patient
of mine
whose husband was getting very
aggressive and actually threatened to
hurt staff
i remember in that moment in my mind
thinking oh what does the book say
and trying to think of the communication
skills that i had learned
i stayed calm and i stayed collected and
by the end of it all
he actually apologized i definitely
would recommend this for anyone because
communication has a huge
impact on our daily lives books four and
five are by the same
author darren hardy and it's the
entrepreneur roller coaster
and the compound effect i unfortunately
don't have these books anymore to show
you
but i believe that you may be able to
find them on the hoopla app
the entrepreneur roller coaster was a
huge game changer for me
because my husband always knew at a
young age that he wanted to be an
employer not an employee but me
i was pretty comfy with being an
employee i didn't have to take big risks
or make big decisions
i never wanted to be an entrepreneur but
when my husband wanted to start a
company
to my very much hesitation i had to
learn
i had to embrace what was very much
outside my comfort zone this book was a
huge blessing to my life because we did
experience many obstacles
losses steps forward and then steps back
i learned that owning a business
is definitely like a roller coaster ride
you have ups and you have downs
but you have to be able to know how to
go down with your arms up in the air
knowing with a firm conviction that
you're going to come back up again so if
being your own bosom day is something
you would like to do or you'd like to
know how to do it better
i definitely recommend this book now the
compound effect
doesn't necessarily apply to business
but rather an overall
improvement in your life i love this
book because it opened my eyes to the
idea that those
seemingly unimportant little habits in
my life are
changing my future drastically and if i
want to achieve a goal that seems
impossible
it really isn't as unattainable as i
make it out to be
because it's all about those seemingly
unimportant decisions
that i make each and every day i love
how darren lays out this book because it
takes you step by step
into analyzing your habits and your
goals and shows you where to make little
tweaks
so that you can get amazing results book
number seven
is a very short read but i loved that it
was and it's the heart of leadership by
mark miller
now don't judge me but i take the
plastic covers off of these things i
like a clear cover okay
i read this book because i started to
notice something at my job
i was a great employee i did above and
beyond what was expected of me
but i never seemed to advance and i
started noticing that other nurses who
had less experience than i did
were being promoted to leadership roles
so i dug a little bit deeper into
leadership and what it takes to become a
leader
this book definitely helped me and it's
one that i plan to reread and it's
actually one that i took notes on and
highlighted and scribbled
it outlines five key characteristics of
a leader and i intentionally
took a long time to read this book
because it kind of gives you a little
bit of homework to do
what i did is i would read one section
and try to actually put this into
practice in my workplace
and in my personal life and then i would
read the next section
for people like me that never quite saw
themselves as a leader
this book is a game changer because it
shows you that leadership is a skill
that you can develop
and he teaches you how it's also a great
book for people who don't exactly love
to read or are just starting to read
because
it's quite small and the chapters are
small and you can read little bits at a
time
and still get huge benefits and last but
definitely not least i get really nerdy
excited about this one
it is never split the difference by
chris voss
i don't have it with me but i actually
really enjoyed this book
because similar to how we already talked
about why communication is so important
chris specifically talks about why
negotiation
is crucial and if you think about it
yeah my toddler negotiates all the time
by throwing a tantrum to see if she gets
what she wants
you negotiate when you decide what
restaurant to go to when you apply for a
raise or a new job
but what about the big negotiations
life-changing negotiations
this book kept me so intrigued like an
action movie because chris
mentions his experiences with working as
a hostage negotiator for the fbi
so he has periods where he's teaching
you negotiation tactics and their
importance
and then he'll go into this really
exciting story that keeps you glued to
find out what happens next
it also shaped my life because it's the
first time that i had ever heard anybody
say
that hearing no when you want something
is actually a good thing
because they're starting to negotiate
with you
and he goes into detail as to how you
can maneuver that
to get to a yes but it is by no means
boring because of his awesome story so
it's actually a really fun read
i learned a lot he's super intelligent
and i'll probably read it again
so there you have it guys seven books
that have made a big impact in my life
there are certainly more but i didn't
want to make this too long
but if you've read any of these let me
know what you think and also let me know
your recommendations on what to read
next
if you like this video please give it a
thumbs up and subscribe so that you
won't miss out on my weekly videos
i thank you so much for watching and i
can't wait to see you in the next one
so you want to know an eighth book that
shaped my life
about three little pigs
[Applause]